all right there is a new resident evil
series on netflix right out of the gate
actually gonna warn you guys there's
some account that's commenting you folks
in the comment section saying hey
because it uses my profile picture and
saying hey you want a drawing for a free
ps5 that's not me doing my best to try
to block and report this account but i'm
pretty sure it's multiple accounts don't
fall for the super shady stupid things
in the internet but again i am trying to
eliminate those all right now let's talk
about this new attempt to make a
resident evil movie or show actually
don't get your hopes up this isn't a
review i made it through exactly two
episodes maybe i'll title this video
that i'm not sure but the point is
here's the premise tell me if this
sounds like resident evil this dad and
his two kids move into this new
neighborhood these kids go to this new
school well that's half the show anyway
yes every episode bounces back and forth
between pre-apocalypse and during the
zombie apocalypse 15 years later it
bounces back and forth dividing the time
among the two timelines pretty evenly
i'd say which means you can view the
show one of two ways you can see it as a
pre-zombie apocalypse show in which it
has just boring generic characters and
then the show flashes forward to during
the zombie apocalypse in which you have
a generic zombie apocalypse that you've
seen a hundred times over on screen or
you can see it as a show that's a
generic zombie apocalypse that you've
seen a hundred times before on screen
that flashes back to the pre-zombie
apocalypse times in which you have
generic characters
rummaging about neither of which really
feels like resident evil so that's kind
of the point here the thing is for the
world pre-zombie apocalypse that
actually could have been a cool take on
the resident evil world only thing is it
would hit hardest if the audience didn't
know it was the resident evil world also
you have to have interesting characters
and a well-written script let's say you
have this family dynamic of this dad and
his two kids and they go to this new
school and they're in this new
neighborhood you don't know the name of
the company that owns all of it but in
the school there's clearly some shady
[ __ ] going on and then at dad's work
there's some shady [ __ ] going on and
it's linked to the school and the kids
are like who owns all of this and it has
all the compelling nature of the first
season of lost of like what's happening
but it's in a high school and at the end
of the first season boom you find out
the name of the company is umbrella the
show's not called resident evil anything
and that's the bomb that's drops like
whoa this is a resident evil prequel
what reminded me of this comic book
series i actually read i think i just
read the first trade but i really
enjoyed it it was a comic book called
morning glories it takes place in high
school but it's super shady and there's
some weird stuff going on it's like lost
meets high school and you're like
what's what's happening but you're
intrigued to know what's happening it
was it was compelling this could have
been like that with resident evil but i
mean the implication there is the
writing has to be good the characters
have to be interesting i feel like
that's on all of us all of us who said
hey resident evil would probably be
better served as a series someone out
there was like series let's do it go i'm
sorry we were so vague i'm sorry we
weren't more specific what we meant is
an interesting series funny enough i
feel like the series might get more of a
break if it wasn't called resident evil
if it wasn't using the resident evil
name it would just be a generic series
that had more promise in its concept
than it delivered in execution as it
stands it's just another poor attempt at
adapting what has got to be the most
impossible video game property to adapt
ever which is resident evil again maybe
it all gets better i only saw two
episodes actually i i was gonna do one
episode then i was like
well i mean one episode's not quite
enough and i'll say that the show seems
to be pretty good at ending an episode
where you're like well i gotta see the
next episode did she live i mean she
just jumped three stories into zombies i
don't know how she's gonna live oh she
did she's okay that's weird not only are
the characters uninteresting but the
dialogue's atrocious future bad guy is
always going cool what are you bad mr
frosty from clay fighter at a point the
girls are like okay we gotta find out
what's in this facility that their dad
works at and with just a recording on
their phone of him going this is albert
wesker the building just goes hello dr
wesker here you go full access when
we're dealing with a world where kevin
mcallister with his talk boy could get
into area 51
are we not dealing with a comedy then i
was like maybe it gets better let me do
the cheat sheet which i usually try not
to do let's just see how it wow
nobody likes this thing this show did
the impossible and that was unite the
internet most people just hate this
thing and i totally see why so i gotta
think it's it's not gonna get better and
in a world where there are shows and
movies i haven't seen i'm fine
not watching the rest of this i'm fine
taking the hours i would have dedicated
to this show and allocating it to better
entertainment or listening to music or
just spending time by myself painting my
warhammer miniatures there's so many
things you can do with time i'm good i'm
out i'm gone because
i know where this is going another poor
attempt at making resident evil i've
seen this a few times before i'm done
dealing with [ __ ] resident evil i'm
gonna ask you about the show cause i'm
tired of asking you what you think about
bad resident evil adaptations the games
are great enjoy the games what's your
favorite resident evil game that'll be
the question whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you